[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther rara caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos sobre la soberanía
europea Y hasta qué punto la Unión
Europea debe incrementar su propia
autonomía y depender menos de Estados
Unidos su gran Aliado y para hablar de
esta cuestión de cómo debe actuar la
Unión Europea si quiere seguir teniendo
un rol relevante en el mundo tenemos con
nosotros aima Rodríguez Piñero del grupo
socialdemócrata bienvenida Inma
Muchísimas gracias encantada de estar
aquí Igualmente gracias por estar aquí y
con Javier nart del grupo renovar Europa
bienvenido Javier gracias muchas gracias
a los dos por estar aquí me gustaría
empezar con Javier recientemente el
presidente francés Emanuel macron ha
creado algo de polémica diciendo que no
hay que seguir exactamente la misma
línea que Estados Unidos respecta a
China especialmente en el conflicto de
Taiwán
Por qué macron dice estas palabras
depende la propia soberanía Europea de
tener su propia agenda o por qué crees
que han creado tanta polémica estas
palabras
durante todo el periodo después de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial Europa ha
renunciado a tener una presencia
estratégica en el mundo para ser una
gran potencia económica y la realidad es
que nos hemos convertido en un gran
estómago pero microcefálico si nosotros
queremos tener una personalidad Eso no
significa tener una confrontación la
alianza con Estados Unidos es
fundamental pero la alianza con Estados
Unidos determina que la distancia entre
Bruselas y Washington es la misma
distancia entre Washington y Bruselas o
sea lo que no puede ser Europa es
determinarse como un seguidismo de
política de otro ni viceversa tenemos
que ser aliados en una situación de
colaborar escucharnos y cooperar
conjuntamente No simplemente un
seguidismo ciego que es lo que hasta
ahora hemos hecho es interesante Esto
del sedismo ciego eima estás de acuerdo
hombre yo creo que sin duda EEUU es un
socio imprescindible para la Unión
Europea yo no creo que sea tan tan
tajante en el sentido de un seguidismo
ciego Pero es verdad que Europa necesita
tener una mayor relevancia una mayor
influencia en el contexto internacional
y eso requiere tener una mayor autonomía
y mayor autonomía no estoy de acuerdo
contigo Javier no implica confrontación
implica ser capaces de identificar bien
cómo defiendes mejor tus intereses y
buscar alianzas con Socios fiables con
Estados Unidos sin duda Pero no solo no
puedes depender de un solo socio en tus
relaciones internacionales ni con china
ni con nadie tienes que ser capaz de
defender tus intereses con el mayor
número posible de socios fiables y
defendiendo el multilateralismo porque
si no somos capaces de defender unas
reglas del juego que sean aceptadas y
aceptables por todos lo que viene es el
cao Y eso es lo que nunca debemos de
consentir Mira está claro que yo no soy
francés soy español como inmaculada Pero
tú observa lo que ha ocurrido en el
Pacífico donde Estados Unidos con otras
potencias anglosajonas que es Australia
y Nueva Zelanda crea el aucus justamente
Perdón nueva zelandano con Australia y
con el Reino Unido crea el aucus que es
la continuidad de esos cinco ojos que
establecieron tras la Segunda Guerra
Mundial esto es la coordinación de los
servicios de inteligencia anglosajones
Canadá incluido etcétera
es curioso porque resulta que en el
Pacífico una de las mayores presencias
es la francesa Cómo se puede establecer
por Estados Unidos una capacidad
estratégica respecto al reto chino que
es un reto absolutamente lógico como
consecuencia de su sobre potencia
económica y también militar excluyendo a
un país que es Francia y en último
término excluyendo lo que también
significa la presencia de la Unión
Europea esto es un error
justamente por
el acuerdo aucus pero también me da
sensación que como que la Unión Europea
también tuvo un poco de decepción con el
acuerdo aucus pero también ha pasado con
la ley de reducción de la inflación como
que Estados Unidos a pesar de ser un
socio fiable No para de decepcionar a la
Unión Europea y desde luego yo creo que
Estados Unidos no se ha comportado como
un socio fiable y Leal a la Unión
Europea no puedes estar hablando con la
Unión Europea teniendo el consejo de
tecnología y comercio donde se han
creado 10 grupos de trabajo específicos
para abordar los grandes desafíos
globales Y en donde estamos Implicados
En Buscar soluciones globales y
conjuntas defendiendo mutuamente
nuestros propios intereses y
unilateralmente aprobar esa ley sin
contar para nada con nosotros ahí
estados unidos no ha estado a la altura
de lo que son unas relaciones
transatlánticas maduras y la Unión
Europea ha tenido que responder con
rapidez y toda la estrategia que se está
desarrollando en torno a las materias
primas críticas en torno a la industria
neta de cero emisiones toda La Apuesta
por las ayudas de estado para que puedan
ser más ambiciosas y proteger a nuestras
industrias que puedan ser más
competitivas es fundamental pero Europa
tiene que ser firme en la respuesta y en
la defensa de los intereses de su
industria porque hemos dejado durante
mucho tiempo de disponer de una política
Industrial europea incluso nacionales y
ese es el gran
responsable de la deslocalización
industrial de la pérdida de tejido
productivo de la pérdida de autonomía
estratégica industrial y que ha hecho
falta dos crisis brutales la de la covid
y la energética para que la Unión
Europea se retrata ante el espejo de la
realidad no puedes depender de un solo
país para el suministro de gas que es
fundamental cuando no tienes gas y tiene
ese Sol y viento para hacer energías
renovables y todo lo que es la apuesta
estratégica que a mí me parece
fundamental por el reciclaje nosotros
tenemos que hacer un desarrollo
tecnológico en la economía circular y
todas aquellas materias primas que no
tenemos y que Son imprescindibles para
hacer el desarrollo de la transición
ecológica y digital como son el litio
las materias raras el cobalto etcétera
obtenerlo del reciclaje porque no lo
tenemos en nuestras Minas y podemos
hacer un esfuerzo en mejorar nuestra
capacidad de adquisición y
diversificación de proveedores pero
nunca va a ser suficiente porque
necesitamos mucho más de lo que ahora
Estamos demandando entonces Europa tiene
que darse cuenta que en nuestra
capacidad de ser estratégicos a nivel
global viene de nuestro poder económico
ni somos un poder militar y no tenemos
es otra capacidad más que nuestra carta
de presentación de los valores
democráticos y libertades y
fundamentales que defendemos y nuestro
poder económico y el poder económico
requiere estrategia industrial y
tecnológica justamente hacía referencia
a la pandemia la autonomía estratégica
también habla un poco de esto porque se
ha hablado mucho en los últimos años se
empezó a hablar ya en 2013 pero
recurrentemente en las conclusiones de
los consejos europeos ha hablado también
de estrategia de autonomía estratégica
primer materia de defensa en seguridad
pero se hace un tubo más con la pandemia
vimos que Europa era incapaz de tener
sus propias mascarillas se ha acomodado
en exceso el bloque de su dependencia
exterior como comentaba Inma la
globalización que en principio tiene un
sentido positivo
ha significado la externalización de
activos estratégicos acabas de hablar
blanco tan elemental como las
mascarillas que ya me contarás la
tecnología punta que se requiere pero lo
que hemos hecho ha sido externalizarlo
porque resulta más barato eso era parte
de un paradigma que en principio era
lógicamente positivo hasta que se rompió
la Baraja se rompió la baraja en la
pandemia y nos dimos cuenta que primero
y era lógico china actuaba en función de
sus propios intereses que estaba
afectada directamente por la pandemia
eso era lógico y la segunda vez donde se
ha roto el paradigma ha sido en el caso
de Ucrania la
estrategia de integrar a Rusia a través
de una participación lo más profunda
posible en los circuitos estratégicos
económicos energéticos y que de esta
forma lo atraíamos hay un momento en que
se rompe cuando Putin toma una decisión
fundamentada en una histeria histórica
que es la negación de una parte de
Ucrania a seguir siendo parte de Ucrania
Eso significa la violación frontal del
acuerdo de helsinki firmado por la Unión
soviética o Rusia el acuerdo de budapest
por el cual se desnuclariza tanto
Bielorrusia como Ucrania y hazastán y en
el caso de budapest se determina que
Rusia es garante también de la
integridad territorial bien no hay una
discrepancia respecto con Estados Unidos
que además es el principal factor de
apoyo económico y militar a Ucrania pero
tampoco en el caso de Taiwán porque la
Unión Europea y también Francia de una
manera clara en el g7 último se ha
determinado y es la política de la Unión
Europea que hay una china pero que hay
un status quo que no es
determinable por cambio a través de
presiones lo que ocurre es que china ha
estado haciendo yo diría la cala del
Melón
Cuál ha sido la cala del Melón las
maniobras militares tras la presencia de
Nancy pelosi que realmente
Enhorabuena por su sentido común o sea
realmente es de una falta de sentido
común absoluta porque ha provocado un
disparadero que es ver si era posible
aislar a Taiwán a través de maniobras
militares lo ha vuelto a hacer hace muy
poco tiempo en consecuencia la capacidad
que tenemos de asistencia Ucrania es
radicalmente distinta de la que
tendremos respecto a Taiwán y hay un
segundo cuestión una segunda cuestión
que es trascendental y es como una
potencia
auto atómica es capaz de imponer una
situación militar
sobre el temor de que la alternativa
pueda ser una guerra nuclear eso le ha
provocado Rusia en Ucrania y China lo
está observando con atención
es justamente sobre el tema de China
además que conoces muy bien tu Inma si
la Unión Europea no puesta por su propia
soberanía tienen peligro de caer tiene
el peligro de caer en la irrelevancia en
unos años entre el empuje de China de
Estados Unidos de India en unos años el
pib de la Unión Europea sólo será el 11%
yo creo que se ha dado cuenta demasiado
tarde pero aún a tiempo y se ha dado
cuenta de que ha ido perdiendo peso
influencia antes lo decía en el tablero
internacional no es increíble como la
Unión Europea ha perdido protagonismo en
regiones como latinoamérica o como
África que ha ocupado China y la verdad
es que la estrategia que lleva china en
defensa exclusivamente de sus intereses
no del desarrollo de esos terceros
países donde invierte no Y la Unión
Europea Yo creo que tiene que
desarrollar una estrategia donde esté
unida la estrategia económica la
estrategia comercial la estrategia
industrial y la estrategia de
cooperación y tiene que
una transición hacia un orden
internacional que sea capaz de crear
unas reglas asumidas asumibles a través
de la Reforma de la Organización Mundial
del Comercio donde China y Estados
Unidos tienen que estar
involucradísimas hoy tenemos aquí a una
delegación de la interparlamentaria de
la Organización Mundial del Comercio
porque vamos a preparar la 51 asamblea
interparlamentaria yo soy miembro de la
comisión ejecutiva y trabajamos
arduamente a nivel parlamentario para
intentar que a nivel institucional y de
los gobiernos se involucren en conseguir
acuerdos eficaces en este sentido
multilateralismo y estrategia de
cooperación y de económica y comercial
es fundamental perfecto Gracias Inma
Javier Lo siento nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo un debate muy interesante Muchas
gracias a los dos a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
Europa hoy Gracias por ver France 24 en
español
[Música]